our President Trump is just not slowing
down and some people in the media and
the left they are having a very hard
time dealing with the fact that he moves
so fast as I like to call it's kind of
moving at the speed of Trump now this
was the president's twenty first visit
to a foreign country in just 18 months
and after today's one-on-one meeting
with Vladimir Putin the two leaders held
a joint press conference let's take a
look I'm here today to continue the
proud tradition of bold American
diplomacy from the earliest days of our
republic American leaders have
understood that diplomacy and engagement
is preferable to conflict and hostility
nothing would be easier politically than
to refuse to meet to refuse to engage
but that would not accomplish anything
as president I cannot make decisions on
foreign policy in a futile effort to
appease partisan critics or the media or
Democrats who want to do nothing but
resist and obstruct now both leaders
they also address the big elephant in
the room and that was election
interference let's watch this the probe
is a disaster for our country I think
it's kept us apart it's kept us
separated there was no collusion at all
everybody knows it people are being
brought out to the fore so far that I
know virtually none of it related to the
campaign and they're gonna have to try
really hard to find somebody that did
relate to the campaign that was a clean
campaign now of course this meeting
comes just days after the Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
announced the indictments of 12 Russian
agents who were accused of hacking the
DNC and the Clinton campaign chairman
John Podesta even though the DNC they
have refused to turn over their hack
server to the FBI when will they turn
that over where is that server a
president Trump weighed in heavily on
this very issue during this joint
precedent let's take a look at this let
me just say that we have two thoughts
you have groups that are wondering why
the FBI never took the server and
haven't they taken the server why was
the FBI told to leave the office of the
kradic National Committee I really
believe that this will probably go on
for a while but I don't think it can go
on without finding out what happened to
the server what happened to the server's
of the Pakistani gentleman that worked
on the DNC where are those servers
they're missing where are they what
happened to Hillary Clinton's emails
33,000 emails gone just gone exactly
what happened to all of those things and
tonight many on the left they want you
to believe this alleged interference is
a shocking unprecedent eternity vents
but we all know that Russia election
meddling is not new at all
now remember ahead of the 2016
presidential election cycle in 2014 the
house Intel Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez he issued a very stern warning
about Putin's belligerent actions and
attempts to denigrate the United States
and by the way
yeah impact our 2016 election and we
also know you can go back to 2008 we
know that Russia hacked into both the
McCain campaign and even the
presidential campaign of Barack Obama
himself and despite this in 2016 when
Hillary Clinton appeared to have a firm
lead in the polls oh just before the
election it was President Obama who
laughed off any notion that American
elections could possibly be tampered
with how wrong he was you may remember
this there is no serious person out
there who would suggest somehow that you
could even you could even rig America's
elections there's no evidence that that
has happened in the past or that there
are instances in which that will happen
this time interesting that's what he
thought Hillary was going to win the
Trump is president after nearly a decade
of playing down Russian interference and
its impact on our elections the left is
in total freakout mode trying
desperately to connect Russia hacking to
the Trump presidency this is a total
left-wing conspiracy a fantasy this is
the witch-hunt every single report every
investigation
into our election show absolutely no
votes were changed
no more altered in the 2016 election not
a single vote and by the way it's
important to point out every major
country in the world engages in election
interference as Senator Rand Paul put it
we all do it and this includes the
Clinton campaign in fact if you're
looking for Russian interference look no
further than Hillary Clinton and the DNC
in 2016 they actually paid oh yeah
through a law firm that they funneled
money Fuzion GPS yeah then they got a
foreign entity for inspired by the name
of Christopher steel he put together
phony opposition research the now
infamous dossier which has been debunked
illed with lies
Russian lies Russia propaganda and all
paid for by Hillary Clinton in the
Democratic Party to manipulate you the
American people and the lead-up to the
2016 election nobody in the media seems
to care about Obama's attempted
interference in the last Israeli
election against our number one ally in
the Middle East Israel and Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and by all
accounts today's meeting was productive
and very important as we all know there
are a lot of serious issues between the
US and Russia but predictably even
before this meeting took place yes the
destroyed Trump hey Trump media they
were already hoping and predicting
failure you see success for Donald Trump
is bad for their agenda especially in
the lead-up to the 2018 midterm
elections take a look we've never had a
summit with a KGB spymaster someone who
has you know completely studied and
examined Donald Trump and a president
who spent the weekend golfing and has
not been preparing what do you think is
going through Putin's mind and how is he
likely to be interpreting president
Trump's behavior he's delighted he's
absolutely delighted he wants to throw
the United States off balance and he
wants to divide the United States with
its allies mission almost accomplished
this has not seemed like a president
who's really going there to really hold
Putin accountable I just don't see how
we can expect anything to come out of
this and why Donald Trump is forcing the
issues
much and it gets even worse take a look
at this despicable cartoon yeah
published by the so called paper record
the New York Times opinion page on
Twitter earlier this morning take a look
do you have a relationship with Vladimir
Putin I do have a relationship with him
and I think he's done a very brilliant
and amazing job he's put himself really
as you know a lot of people would say
he's put himself at the forefront of the
world as a leader now that's your
corrupt mainstream media pretty
disgusting now naturally the anti-trump
hatred the hysteria continued after
today's meeting
look at this former CIA director you
know the guy that was a former communist
turned CNN paid hack John Brennan he
actually tweeted out Donald Trump's
press conference performance in Helsinki
rises to and exceeds the thresholds of
high crimes and misdemeanors it was
nothing short of treasonous not only
what trumps comments in bellick he is
wholly in the pocket of Putin Republican
Patriots where are you John let's
address you for a second here what have
you done on Obama's watch to prevent
Russia meddling what role did you play
in all this now you've just undermined
this country and frankly you should be
ashamed let's take a look at this
corruption we are under attack from
Russia if there were physical missiles
like during the missile missile crisis
Americans would be in the streets and
protesting and asking for the President
to protect us these are invisible
missiles it's time for Americans to be
out on the streets and to speak up about
the democracy that we hold dear the
values we hold dear and what we expect
of the President of the United States
you have been watching perhaps one of
the most disgraceful performances by an
American president at a summit in front
of a Russian leader joining that I've
ever seen as you can see it was all a
predetermined outcome it didn't matter
what happened at today's meeting your
mainstream media just blind hatred for
president Trump and they long
predetermined that anything the
president does is terrible it's
devastating apocalypse
and at this point they're just a broken
record now on this show we're not afraid
to report that with the mainstream media
will not report and we've been proven
right
we're not blinded by the same
pathological hate of all things Donald
Trump look at the economy look at the
progress in North Korea and while the
left always acts like the sky is
literally falling because Donald Trump
actually wants to discuss safety and
security with nuclear weapons nuclear
proliferation Syria Iran and a lot of
other important issues including
interference by the way meeting with
Putin is that bad we all know the truth
u.s. diplomacy is in good hands
in spite of what they tell you the
president has never been afraid to walk
away from a bad deal and they've been
afraid to call out world leaders and
hold all of them accountable as we saw
he was critical of the British
government's execution and breaks it and
by the way he rightly called out many of
our allies in NATO why they're not
paying their fair share for their own
national defense even criticizing the
German Chancellor Angela Merkel and her
country's lucrative energy deal with
Vladimir Putin's Russia which creates a
dangerous dependency on Russia in energy
which is the lifeblood of their economy
after all the West is so worried about
Russia well why would they be willing to
give him billions and billions of
dollars to make Russia rich again
instead the president is now rightly
pushing Germany to kill its oil and gas
deals with Russia and get their energy
from us in the United States which would
also mean millions of high-paying career
jobs for Americans now this move would
not only benefit the United States it
would also absolutely wreck Russia's
economy now Putin should be very
concerned about that possibility as it
would literally destroy Russia's economy
and probably destroy him politically
we'll have more on that in a moment the
president has been even more forceful
with our enemies look at North Korea
little rocket man fire in fury our
button works yours does it and it's
bigger now despite what the media
predicted is a real progress on the
Korean Peninsula because the president's
peace through strength
strategy is working it always works
appeasement doesn't work bribing
dictators doesn't
now there hasn't been a single rocket
fired in months American hostages thank
God they have come home one nuclear site
in fact has been dismantled and
shuttered and the process continues to
this day
and this is something else that the
mainstream media will never tell you
President Trump has been incredibly
tough on Russia this is something they
won't report under his administration
the u.s. issued sanctions against
roughly 200 individuals and entities
related to Russia other stinging
economic sanctions against Russia have
also increased and US forces on the
ground in Syria inflicted heavy
casualties on even Russian soldiers
during a skirmish earlier this year an
enormous of bear embarrassment for
Vladimir Putin and the United States has
been busy arming Ukraine with lethal
weapon systems but the media they're not
going to focus on any of this instead
it's Russia Russia Russia collusion
collusion collusion if they're not
talking about stormy it's all the time
it's 24/7 now what this is a backdrop
the president rules forward with what is
very important diplomacy and as the
leader of the free world president from
he must meet with the leaders of Russia
China North Korea and others as long as
he's not sending 150 billion dollars in
your cash and other currencies now our
friends our foes they know where we
stand they need to hear it from the
commander-in-chief there is as you say a
new sheriff in town let the president
negotiate deals that Obama was not
capable of and specifically Russia must
stop coordinating with the Iranian
regime they must stop supporting
President Assad in Syria and yes they
need to stop yea meddling in anybody's
elections and be held accountable for
their actions the years of weak and
feckless leadership under Obama are now
over no more cargo planes full of cash
and as president Trump frequently says a
good relationship with Putin and Russia
when you're not trying to bribe them is
a very positive thing for the country
however under President Trump any
hostile or aggressive action by Putin's
regime will be and should be met with
strength not appeasement not bribery not
cash not kissing the rings of dictators
and while the mainstream media in
America
left as they peddle their conspiracy
theories well the administration is now
putting forth some truth and some
precedent and some fact and by the way
Reagan proved it to all of us peace
through strength works diplomacy is
important trust but verify and the
American people's safety and security
frankly is dependent on all of this our
kids our grandkids this matters